there we had deregulation Obamacare
borders and wall cut taxes and trade all
right at the very beginning so how is he
going to organize all this what comes
first what comes second yeah well it's a
good question so i think we think he's
going to be focused on the areas where
he can sort of put points on the board
and those are the areas where he has
hurt executive authority trade is one of
those i think withdrawing from the TPP
he can do that without congressional
authority were expecting him to do that
today if not this if not later this week
immigration he can ramp up and force to
it without congressional approval and
then on some of these executive orders
that would scale back the obama
regulations the other things however
obamacare tax reform infrastructure
those are all subject to congressional
approval and as we know the legislative
process is time-consuming it's iterative
and those things are going to take much
longer so it's been a lot of talk about
obamacare the affordable care act as you
say they need congressional legislation
to do that there are two alternatives
repeal and then think about it down the
road repeal and replace at the same time
what's the difference in terms of the
timing for congress yeah and that's
really important i suspect that
congressional Republican leaders really
just wanted to advance with a repeal
bill that would have been easy and
there's precedent for it it's something
a similar bill passed in the last
Congress however when Donald Trump came
over came out several weekends ago
saying that he's actually going to
replace simultaneously I can just
imagine what congressional Republicans
were thinking oh goodness because you
know that has a chance of sort of
hijacking their congressional agenda
over health care overhaul is incredibly
difficult to put it in perspective
President Obama when he entered office
had an approval rating of seventy-eight
percent he had larger majorities in both
the Senate in the house and Obamacare
took 14 months to pass and even then it
passed on a party-line vote so these are
really difficult really complex things
and I hate to be sort of you know
pouring cold water over the animal
spirits but you know legislating is is
difficult now the question is on what
was a Friday or Saturday he wound up
having an executive order declaring his
administration would repeal Obamacare
but no one really knew what that meant
that's a sign that executive order what
does it actually do for insurers for a
hospital right exactly so it'd just be
sidley gives discretion to the Secretary
of Health and Human Services who hasn't
actually even been confirmed yet to
evaluate where they can actually roll
back some of the things that we're done
by executive order the thing about
Obamacare is that the bulk of it was
passed by Congress but it also gave the
executive the president obama at the
time a lot of discretion to fill in the
details and as a result president Trump
now has the ability to roll some of
those things back but I think to your
point the individual mandate is really
the big question does he touch that and
if he does then as we know that that
could lead have some pretty significant
consequences for the insurance in market
Libby let's say I'm an investor I've
just spent the weekend looking at crowd
sizes some news conferences over the
White House and I'm wondering I've got
big consensus positions on and playing
this big reflation trade and I hear
nothing about fiscal stimulus all I hear
about is Obamacare inauguration crowd
sizes and things like that a wake up
Monday morning where's the fiscal
stimulus plan yes so I think you're
right in terms of tax reform there was
no mention of tax reform over the last
60 hours however he did emphasize
infrastructure I was actually surprised
by how much he talked about
infrastructure in his inaugural speech
and I think that that is somewhat a side
effect of Stephen bannon's influence
Stephen Bannon has been said that he's
been very supportive of infrastructure
but I think you're right this is where
sort of the rubber meets the proverbial
Road governing is harder than
campaigning and these things especially
when they're subject to congressional
approval just take a lot longer so
they're doing Obamacare I mean again
that could take up an entire year and
then that would push back tax reform and
infrastructure because we haven't even
see legislation about how those things
would work the timing could even be
pushed back farther